Now it's time for you to use that
installed software and build the images.
We've provided all the files
in a Github repository.
You should go ahead and
clone it to your local workstation.
The files for this exercise are in
the packer templates directory.
If you look in applicationsurfer.json,
you'll see that here we're
using shell provisioners.
That's just for simplicity, so
you don't have to learn a new syntax.
Even if you're not familiar with
shell scripts, don't worry.
Take a look at some of them.
Notice that they're just a file, and
in that file you'll just see
one command after another.
It's also possible in Packer to use
other provisioners, like Chef or
Puppet or Ansible or Salt.
These can provide more
advanced functionality.
You can see the provisioners listed
here in applicationserver.json.
And each one points to one or
more files in the scripts directory.
They'll run in the order
they are listed.
An interesting note is
the provisioners are used for
all builders unless specified otherwise.
As you can see, there's a couple
of scripts that are run only for
the virtual box iso builder.
Okay enough talk.
Go ahead and clone the repo changed
to the packer templates directory and
follow the instructions in the readme or
in the instructionettes.
When you run the packer build,
it will take a while,
after all it first has to download
the OS image, then install nvm,
then install all the software, then at
the end compress and save the image.
Once you do that a look through
the application-server.json file and
see if you can answer these questions.
First, what directory does
the post-processor save the final
artifact in?
There's a variable for it.
Enter that variable,
including the curly braces around it.
And second, what's the file
extension for the final artifact?
Put that here.